eran la juventud Santiago Peña era
director del Banco Central a los 32 años
y fue el ministro de hacienda más joven
de Paraguay promete crear 500.000
puestos de trabajo en un país de 6,7
millones de personas y en entrevista
para France 24 prometió reducir el 30%
de pobreza del país y se va a solucionar
se puede solucionar Y es inaceptable que
en un país tan rico como el Paraguay que
pueda alimentar a 80 millones de
personas en el mundo tengamos personas
que no pueden completar una ración
mínima de alimento es el candidato
oficialista a pese a las diferencias que
mantiene con el saliente presidente
Mario abdo Benítez Peña es visto como el
delfín del expresidente Horacio cartes
líder del partido Colorado quienes
considerado el mandatario en la sombra y
quien goza de Gran popularidad Pese a
que kartés fue sancionado por Estados
Unidos por corrupción el candidato
Colorado brinda apoyo a quien confió en
él como ministro hemos pedido todo es
que se defienda que no escatime
esfuerzos en rebatir todas estas
acusaciones donde hasta ahora
lastimosamente él no ha tenido la
posibilidad de defenderse
pese a los problemas con Estados Unidos
Santiago Peña promete mantener su apoyo
a Taiwán sin embargo en política
internacional ya ha tenido problemas
después de llamar vagos a los argentinos
en el ámbito local ha elogiado la
dictadura de stresner Y ante la
diversidad lgbt o el aborto se sitúa al
lado de la que considera familia
tradicional es la puesta conservadora
para mantener la hegemonía colorada